let's start with a big question what is
nuclear fusion is the underlying process
that powers the universe
so as the name implies it fuses together
or brings together
two different elements technically
nuclei that come together and if you can
push them together close enough that you
can trigger essentially a reaction what
happens is that the the element
typically changes so this means that you
change from one element to another
chemical element to another underlying
what this means is that you change the
nuclear structure this rearrangement
through equals mc squared releases large
amounts of energy so Fusion is the
fusing together of lighter elements into
heavier elements and when you go through
it you say oh look so here are the
initial elements typically hydrogen and
they had a particular Mass rest Mass
which means just the mass when they're
with no kinetic energy and when you look
at the product afterwards it has less
rest mass and so you go well how is that
possible because you have to keep Mass
but mass and energy are the same thing
which which is what equals mc squared
means and the the conversion of this
comes into kinetic energy namely energy
that you can use in some way and that's
what happens in the center of stars so
Fusion is literally the reason life is
is viable in the universe so Fusion is
happening in our sun and what are the
elements the elements are hydrogen that
are coming together it goes through a
process which just probably gets a
little bit too detailed but there's it's
a somewhat complex catalyzed process
that happens in the center of stars but
in the end stars are Big Balls of
hydrogen which is the lightest it's the
simplest element the lightest element
the most abundant element most of the
universe is hydrogen and it's
essentially a sequence through which
these processes occur that you end up
with helium
so those are the primary things and the
reason for this is because
helium has features as a nucleus like
the interior part of the atom that is
extremely stable and the reason for this
is helium has two protons and two
neutrons these are the things that make
up nuclei that make up all of us along
with electrons and because it has two
pairs it's extremely stable and for this
reason it when you convert the hydrogen
into helium it just wants to stay helium
and it wants to release kinetic energy
so stars are basically conversion
engines of hydrogen into helium and I
mean this also tells you why you love
Fusion I mean because our sun will last
you know 10 billion years approximately
that's along the fuel will last but to
do that kind of conversion you have to
have extremely high temperatures it is
one of the criteria for doing this but
it's the easiest one to understand and
why is this it's because
effectively what this requires is that
these hydrogen uh ions or which is
really the bare nucleus so they have a
positive charge everything has a
positive charge of those ones is that to
get them to to trigger this reaction
they must approach within distances
which are like the size of the nucleus
itself because the nature in fact what
it's really using is something called
the strong nuclear force there's four
fundamental forces in the universe this
is the strongest one but it has a
strange property is that it while it's
the strongest force by far it only has
impact over distances which are the size
of a nucleus so to get let's put that
into what does that mean it's a
millionth of a billionth of a meter okay
incredibly small distances but because
the distances are small and the
particles have charge they want to push
strongly apart namely they have
repulsion that wants to push them apart
so it turns when you go through the math
of this the average velocity or energy
of the particles must be very high to
have any significant probability of the
reactions happening and so the center of
our sun is at about 20 million degrees
Celsius
and on Earth this means it's one of the
first things we teach you know entering
graduate students you can do a quick you
can do a quick basically Power Balance
and you can you can determine that on
Earth that it requires a minimum
temperature of about 50 million degrees
Celsius on Earth
to perform Fusion to get enough Fusion
that you would be able to make get
energy gain out of it
so you can trigger Fusion reactions at
lower energy but they become almost
vanishingly small at lower temperatures
than that
first of all let me just link on some
crazy ideas so uh one the strong voice
just stepping out and looking at all the
physics
is it weird to you that there's these
forces and they're very particular like
it operates at a very small distance
then gravity operates at a very large
distance and and they are all very
specific in the standard model describes
uh three of those forces extremely well
and there's and this is one of them and
yeah this is one of them it's just all
kind of works out there's a big part of
you that's uh you know an engineer that
used to step back and almost look at the
philosophy of physics
so it's interesting because as a
scientist I see the universe through
that lens of essentially the interesting
things that we do are through the forces
that are get used around those and
everything works because of that
Richard Feynman had uh I don't know if
you've ever had Richard fine it's a
little bit of a tangent but he's never
been on the pocket he's never been on
the podcast he was unfortunately passed
away but wanted like a like a hero to
almost all all physicists and then part
of it was because of what you said he
kind of looked through a different lens
at these but typically look like very
dry like equations and relationships and
he kind of I think he brought out the
Wonder of it in some sense right for for
those he posited what would be if you
could write down a single not even
really a sentence but a single concept
that was the most important thing
scientifically that we that we knew
about that in other words you had only
one thing that you could transmit like a
future or past generation it was very
interesting it was um so it's not what
you think it wasn't like oh strong
nuclear force or Fusion or something
like this and it's very profound which
was he was that the reason that matter
operates the way that it does is because
all matter is made up of individual
particles that interact each other
through forces that was it suggests that
atomic theory basically yeah
which is like wow that's like so simple
but it's not so simple it's because like
who thinks about atoms that they're made
out of like I I this is a good this is a
good question I give to my students how
many atoms are in your body like almost
no students can answer this but to me
that's like a fundamental thing by the
way it's about 10 to the 28 out of 28.
so that's uh you know trillion or you
know million trillion trillion or
something like that yes so one thing is
to think about the number and the other
is to start to really Ponder the fact
that it all holds together yeah it all
holds together and you're actually that
you're more that than you are anything
else yes exactly yeah no I mean there
are people who do study such things of
the fact that if you look at the for
example the ratios between those
fundamental forces people have figured
out oh if this ratio was different by
some Factor like a factor of two or
something that's like oh this would all
like not work and I look you look at the
sun right it's like so it turns out that
there are key reactions that if they had
slightly lower or probability no star
would ever ignite and then life wouldn't
be possible it does seem like the the
universe set things up for us that it's
possible to do some cool things but it's
challenging so that that keeps it fun
for us yeah yeah that's the way I look
at it I mean the you know the Multiverse
model is an interesting one uh because
there are you know Quantum scientists
who look at the fear I was like oh it's
like oh yeah like Quantum science
perhaps tells us that there are almost
an infinite you know variety of other
universes but the way that it works
probably is it's almost like a form of
natural selection it's like well the
universes that didn't have the correct
or interesting relationships between
these forces nothing happens in them so
almost by definition the fact that we're
having this conversation means that
we're in one of the interesting ones by
default
yeah one of the somewhat interesting but
there's probably super interesting ones
we I I tend to think of humans as
incredible creatures our brain is is an
incredible Computing device but
I think we're also extremely cognitively
limited I can imagine
alien civilizations that are much much
much much more intelligent uh in ways we
can't even comprehend in terms of their
ability to come to construct models of
the world and to do physics to do
physics and Mathematics I would see it
in a slightly different way it's
actually it's because we have
um we have we have creatures that live
with us on the earth that have cognition
right that understand and move through
their environment but they they actually
see things in a way or they sense things
in a way which is so fundamentally
different it's really hard like the TR
it's it it's the problem is the
translation not necessarily intelligence
so it's the perception of the world so I
have a dog and when I go out and I see
my dog like smelling things there's a
realization that I have that he sees or
senses the world in a way that I can
never like I can't understand it because
I can't translate my way to this we get
little glimpses of this as humans though
by the way because there are some parts
of it for example Optical information
which comes from light isn't now because
we've developed the technology we can
actually see things you know I've had I
get this you know as a one of my areas
of research is spectroscopy so this
means the study of light you know and I
and I get this quote unquote see things
or representation of them from you know
the far infrared all the way to like
hard hard x-rays which is several orders
of magnitude of the of the light
intensity but our own human eyes like
see a teeny teeny little sliver of this
yeah so that even like bees for example
see a different place than we do so I
don't I I think if you think of there's
already other intelligences like around
us in a way in a limited way
um because of the way they can
communicate but it's like those are
already baffling in many ways yeah so if
we just focus in on the senses there's
already a lot of diversity but there's
probably things we're not even
considering as possibilities for example
uh whatever the heck Consciousness is
could actually be a door into
understanding some physical phenomena
we're not I haven't even begun
understanding so just like you said
spectroscopy there could be a similar
kind of spectrum for Consciousness that
we're just like we're like these dumb uh
descendants of Apes like walking around
it sure feels like something to
experience the color red but like we
don't have
it's the same as in the ancient times
you experience physics you experience
light it's like oh it's bright and you
know yeah yeah and you construct kind of
uh what's interesting we might actually
experience this faster than we thought
because we might be building another
another kind of intelligence yeah and
that that intelligence will explain to
us how silly we are there was an email
thread going around the professors in my
department already of uh so what is it
going to look like to figure out if
students have actually written their
term papers or it's chat
chat GPT
um uh it was so as usual as it is where
you we tend to be empiricists in my
field so of course they were in there
like trying to figure out if uh if it
could answer like questions for a
qualifying exam to get into the PHD
program
T which was they didn't do that well at
that point but of course this is just
the beginning of it so we have some
interesting ones to go eventually both
the students and the professors will be
replaced by Chad GPT yeah and we'll sit
on the beach I really recommend you know
this I don't know if you've ever seen
them it's called the day the universe
changed
this is James Burke he's a science
historian based in the UK um he had a
had a fairly famous series on on public
television called connections I think it
was but the one that I really enjoyed
was the day the universe changed and the
the reason for the title of it was that
um he says the universe is what we know
and perceive of it so when there's a
fundamental insight as to something new
the universe for us changes of course
the universe from an objective point of
view is the same as it was before but
for us it has changed so he walks
through these these moments of
perception in in in in the history of
humanity that like changed what we were
right and so as I was thinking about
coming to to discuss this you know
people see Fusion oh it's still far away
or we've been it's been slow progress
It's like when my when my godmother was
born like people had no idea how Stars
worked
so you talk about like that day that
Insight the universe changed it's like
oh this is the I mean and they still
didn't understand all the parts of it
but you know they basically got it it's
like oh because of the because of the
understanding of these processes it's
like we unveiled the reason that there
can be life in the universe that's
probably one of those days the universe
changed right yeah and that was
remembered 1930s yeah it seems like
technology is developing faster and
faster and faster
I tend to think that Jessica gbt I think
this year might be extremely interesting
just with how rapid and how profitable
the efforts in artificial intelligence
are that just stuff will happen where
our whole world is transformed like this
and we're there's a shock and then next
day you kind of go on and you adjust
immediately uh you probably won't have a
similar kind of thing with uh nuclear
fusion with energy because there's
there's probably going to be an opening
ceremony and stuff an announcement it'll
take months but with uh with digital
technology you can just have a immediate
transformation of society and then it'll
be this gasp and then you kind of adjust
like we always do and then you go don't
even remember just like with the
internet and so on how the days work
before and how did it worked before
right yeah I mean Fusion will be because
it's energy it's it's nature is that it
will be um and anything that has to do
with energy use tends to be a slower
transition but they're the most I would
argue for some of the most profound
transitions that we make I mean the
reason that we can live like this and
sit in this building and have this
podcast and people around the world is
at his heart is energy use and it's
intense energy use that came from the
evolution of starting to use intense
Energies at the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution up to now it's
that it's like it's a Bedrock actually
of all of these but it doesn't tend to
come overnight yeah and some of the most
important some of the most amazing
Technologies one we don't notice because
we take it for granted because it
enables this whole thing yeah which is
energy which is amazing for how
fundamental it is to our society and way
of life is a very poorly understood
concept actually just even energy itself
people confuse energy sources with
energy storage with energy transmission
these are different physical phenomena
which are very important for so for
example
you know you buy an electric car and you
go oh good I have an emission free car
and uh ah but it's like so so why do you
say that well it's because if I draw the
circle around the car I have electricity
and it doesn't emit any anything okay
but you plug that into a grid where you
follow that wire back there could be a
coal power plant or a gas powered plant
at the end of that oh really I mean so
this isn't like carbon free oh and it's
not their fault it's just you know they
don't like the car isn't a source of
energy the underlying source of energy
was the combustion of the fuel back
somewhere plus there's also a story of
how the raw materials are mined in which
parts of the world uh with sort of basic
respect or or deep disrespect of human
rights that happens in that money so the
whole supply chain there's a story there
that's deeper than just the particular
electric car with a circle around it in
the physics or the science of it too is
the energy use that it takes to do that
digging up which is also important and
all that yeah anyway so yeah we wandered
away from Fusion but yes
but it's very important actually to in
the in the context of this just because
you know those of us who work in
infusion and these other kinds of
um sort of disruptive Energy
Technologies it's it's interesting I do
think about like what would it what is
it going to mean to society to have an
energy source that is like this
um that that would be like Fusion you
know which has which is such completely
different characteristics
you know for example you know free
unlimited access to the fuel but it has
technology implications so what does
this mean geopolitically what does it
mean for how we how we distribute wealth
within our society it's
it's very difficult to know but probably
profound